I think the most important technologies
that we have are those that we've had
for decades already.
One small example of that would be oral
rehydration therapy,
which is a simple solution of sugar,
salt,
and water,
which can save the lives of severely
dehydrated people,
people dehydrated by cholera or a
intestinal worms,
which has resulted in severe diarrhea.
I've actually seen kids who actually
come back from death.
They're,
they're literally hours from dying.
You give them the simple solution in the
right quantity of oral rehydration
therapy and they're up running around
playing soccer.
So why isn't that being used everywhere
in the world?
The answer is that the management,
the wherewithal and the overall a unity
of focus on public health does not
currently exist in so many countries.
Instead,
they might be trying more complex
solutions,
sophisticated antibiotics,
uh,
other,
interventions such as intravenous drips,
which can't be administered in all
resource poor settings.
So it's really a mixed perspective.
I think that there's a lot to be said
for new Po,
portable Ekg,
akgs,
and also electronic medical records.
But overall,
I think first we've got to figure out
how do we roll out the technologies that
we've got a lot of practice with,
which we know are extremely effective.
And those are technologies like
insecticide treated bed nets or
combination therapy for malaria or
antiretroviral therapy for HIV aids.
These are all very basic interventions,
which have been with us at least a
decade,
if not decades,
more than that.
And yet they're not currently being
implemented across the board.
There's actually some new vaccines which
have just come to market and are
starting to be used in developing
countries,
including a vaccine for pneumonia,
pneumococcal vaccine,
which we just piloted in Rwanda.
That's going to save 6,000 lives,
and it's just one shot in the arm that
kids need,
uh,
periodically,
and they're going to be good and it's
going to end up saving more lives than
lots of more sophisticated intervention.